on se dit tiens ça sert à quoi
non je suis pas tellement normal chacun
de ça mais je vais lui laisser un
message
je garde absolument tous mes messages de
répondeur depuis 15 ans aujourd'hui ce
que je m'amuse à faire c'est que bon
j'ai pas mal de deux copains et je
pourrais les appeler x ou y mais je les
appelais marco et norbert ci s'appelle
comme ça et je prends un message qu'un
copain m'a laissé parents de marc coma a
laissé ce message sur mon répondeur il
ya cinq ans est ce que je fais je le
laisse sur le répondeur de norbert
aujourd'hui sur que l'autre l'autre qui
reçoit le message il est pourquoi il m'a
appelé parce que j'étais avec lui à 5
minutes
donc il le rappelle il dit mais pourquoi
tu m'appeler marco leal je t'ai jamais
appelée où il commence à s'engueuler et
norbert lui fait écouter son message qui
m'était destiné au départ marcourt
connaît sa voie il deviens fou relégable
a balayé hier j'ai toutes les cassettes
je comprends les stocker sur ordinateur
mais donc c'est ainsi un véritable peut
donc et je m'amuse à faire ça dans le
fait qu'ils ont un oui bon personnel
c'est sur scène